let's talk about stress and stress  optimization you want to have just  enough effort in the areas that bring  you purpose but you also want to control  your stress fortunately we are  concentrated on the self-actualization  part of Maslow's hierarchy of needs so  we're not as concerned with our physical  or bare essential needs but the level of  stress is still there when the stress is  not proportionate to the threat it can  be unnecessary and it can affect your  Hormone Health and it can affect the  health of the rest of your households as  well life is extraordinarily difficult  and you want to be able to have a  positive mindset or a glass half full or  even glass quarter full  outlook on your stress there's a lot of  tools like mindfulness or meditation or  even prayer or even just walking and  being around green plants and trees can  be helpful